right um
last one last one come on guys
our next presenter starred in netflix's
bird box
a movie where people survive by acting
like they don't see a thing
sort of like working for harvey
weinstein
you did it you i didn't you did it
to begin i just want to congratulate
harvey i'd like to thank harvey
weinstein harvey weinstein harvey
weinstein
harvey weinstein harvey and bob
weinstein harvey weinstein and then
harvey weinstein harvey weinstein
harvey and bob weinstein
thank you harvey weinstein
i want to thank harvey and bob weinstein
my agent kevin euvain and god
harvey weinstein
i love this next presenter he's so cool
um
[Music]
he's the star of iron man two girls and
a guy
wonder boys
sorry these porn films what
kiss kiss bang bang
bow finger really
yeah up the academy come on
he has done all those films but many of
you in this room probably know him best
from such facilities as the betty ford
clinic and los angeles county jail
please welcome robert downey jr
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
aside from the fact uh that has been
hugely mean-spirited with mildly
sinister undertones i say the vibe of
the show is pretty good so far wouldn't
you
the world got to see james corden as a
fat [ __ ]
he was also in the movie cats but
no one saw that um
and the reviews are shocking i saw one
that said this is the worst thing to
happen to cats since dogs right
but dame judi dench defended the film
saying it was the role she was born to
play because she
i can't do this next
because she loves nothing better than
plonking herself down on the carpet
lifting her leg and licking her
[Applause]
furball verbal
she's old school um
it's the last time who cares
but as i say i'm going to be nice
tonight i've changed
not as much as bruce jenner obviously
now caitlyn jenner of course what a year
she's had
she became a role model for trans people
everywhere showing great bravery in
breaking down barriers and destroying
stereotypes
she didn't do a lot for women drivers
but
i've
changed not as much as bruce jenner
obviously
now caitlyn jenner of course what a year
she's had
she became a role model for trans people
everywhere showing great bravery in
breaking down barriers and destroying
stereotypes
she didn't do a lot for women drivers
but
you can't have everything
also not nominated i love you philip
morris um jim jim carrey and euro
mcgregor two heterosexual actors
pretending to be gay
so the complete opposite of some famous
scientologist then
um probably
is the star of the hilarious comedy the
martian
i nearly died right
he's also the only person who ben
affleck hasn't been unfaithful to
please welcome matt damon
[Applause]
thank you um
what can i say about our next two
presenters
the first is an actor producer writer
and director whose movies have grossed
over three and a half billion dollars at
the box office he's won two academy
awards and three golden globes for his
powerful and varied performances
starring in such films as philadelphia
forrest gump
castaway apollo 13 and saving private
ryan
the other is tim allen
[Music]
you know like like many of you
we recall back when ricky gervais was a
slightly chubby but very kind comedian
yeah
neither of which is he now
it is an honor to be here um in a room
full of what i consider to be the most
important people on the planet actors
they're just
they're just better than ordinary people
aren't they that's no they're
we all know that um
imagine a world without actors oh god it
doesn't matter think about imagine if
they ever went on strike oh
what would we do you couldn't replace
them you couldn't replace them with any
other profession lawyers or doctors can
you imagine a real surgeon doing what
hugh laurie does in house it would be
pathetic
he'd be all over the place we don't know
where do i stand how's my american
accent what's my lines you know hugh
with the aid of coaches i can eventually
learn his lines while saving lives he's
a genius
how could you replace kiefer sutherland
in 24 i'd love to see a real
anti-terrorist agent trying to fuse a
bomb in a busy train station in one hour
some of those scenes by the way where
kefir grabs on and beats him to a pulp
they weren't even in the script
the director just said keep rolling
we're working into them
but actors aren't just loved here in
hollywood they are loved the world over
because they're recognizable you can be
anywhere you could be in the third world
okay and you get a glimpse of a
hollywood star and it makes you feel
better okay you could be a little a
little child a little asian child with
no possessions and no money but you get
a you see a picture of angelina jolie
and you think mummy
[Applause]
thank you
let's get on with it before
nbc replaced me with jay leno um
no one cares about movies anymore no one
goes to cinema no one really watches
network tv everyone's watching netflix
this show should just be me coming out
going well done netflix you win
everything good night but no no we gotta
drag it out for three hours you could
binge watch the entire first season of
afterlife instead of watching this show
that that's a show about a man who wants
to kill himself because his wife dies of
cancer and it's still more fun than this
okay
spoiler alert um season two is on the
way so in the end he obviously didn't
kill himself
just like jeffrey epstein
shut up i know he's your friend but i
don't care
our next presenter
is the queen of pop
not you elton sit down this is
she's all woman i'll give you some clues
she's always vogue
she's a material girl
and she's just like a virgin
please welcome madonna
[Music]
[Applause]
if i'm still
just like a virgin ricky
then why don't you come over here and do
something about it
[Applause]
i haven't kissed a girl in a few years
on tv
don't be so shy just tell me what you
like
[Music]
with a morning show a superb drama yeah
a superb drama about the importance of
dignity and doing the right thing made
by a company that runs sweatshops in
china so well you say you woke but the
companies you work for i mean
unbelievable apple amazon disney if isis
started a streaming service you'd call
your agent wouldn't you so
if you do win an award tonight
pl don't use it as a platform to make a
political speech right you're in no
position to lecture the public about
anything you know nothing about the real
world most of you spent less time in
school than greta thundberg so if you
win right
come up accept your little award thank
you agent and your god
so
it's already three hours long
there were a lot of big films that
didn't get nominated this year nothing
for sex in the city too um
no i was sure the golden globe for
special effects would go to the team
that airbrushed that poster um
what
the excellent spotlight has been
nominated yeah
the uh the catholic church are furious
about the film as it exposes the fact
that five percent of all their priests
have repeatedly molested children and
been allowed to continue to work without
punishment
roman polanski called it the best date
movie ever
the irishman
was amazing it was amazing um that
it was my face
it was great
long
but amazing um
it wasn't the only epic movie once upon
a time in hollywood nearly three hours
long leonardo dicaprio attended the
premiere and by the end his date was too
old for him
even prince andrew is like come on leo
mate you know
you're nearly 50 son
um
you probably know me as the creator of
the office
no you don't do you you think steve
corral did it all oh
he's brilliant isn't he steve corral
he's amazing as the bumbling office
manager where does he get his ideas from
let's pay
let's pay him hundreds of millions of
dollars and put him in every movie
if you can't be bothered to go to the
cinema to see steve in action then um
just watch him every thursday here on
nbc
[Applause]